Hello, everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome back to Subnautica.
Now in this episode, I plan to do something very, very stupid.
Because I'm about to take this Cyclops into the territory of where the Sea Leviathans are.
And if you know what that means, it means I'm probably gonna die
a horrible death and I'm gonna lose my Cyclops and everything I know and love is going to
explode, and die.
But before we do that, I've actually made some changes!
I'm back now to the release version of the game
AND, I've tweaked the save files so that all of the things I've opened before are now no longer open.
So, if I go over to this life pod, that may sound complicated,
It's not cheating, I didn't actually give myself anything, all I did was delete some save game files
That made it so that THIS
Was no longer open!
And here it is, it actually worked, I can't believe it
So if I open this,
I'm in the retail version of it now, this SHOULD give me,
THE CREATURE DECOY!
So I have that now, I HAVE that now, it WORKS
AND - I'll take this first aid kit 'cause why not -
and I got the Lifepod 4 Crew Log
So, the unfortunate thing is everything I've picked up is no longer
Or, is there to be picked up again.
But then benefit is
I think I still have everything that I've picked up
Thus far
So I didn't lose anything and I've only
gained that which is new that I haven't already gotten
Like these Creature Decoys. So,
If I go back into my cyclops right now
(Welcome Aboard Captain, All Systems online) - And I go up here-Oh its always good to be welcomed aboard,
Lemmie get back here and actually talk to my people about this thing
Thanks buddy.
And If I-Ahhh...
But I thought it was here? The cyclops upgrade fabricator
Or maybe the decoy isn't made there...
Maybe the decoy is made....
Somewhere else...
Like in the actual fabricator
Because that's where that would be...
YES-HEYY!! THERE IT IS!
THERE-OOHH I PISSED MYSELF IN SUCH JOY! OVER THAT FACT!
I've got a bet that I could make that no problem.
Titanium, Copper wire, and a battery?
I've got bonus batteries sitting back in my old base
I've got a ton of em!
So if I-Uh-Im gonna reclaim those because that's actually good, because it doesn't matter if those batteries are full, or empty
No matter what they are
You can still use them
And if i'm going against the sea dragon leviathans
Or not the sea dragon leviathans, just...the leviathans
The Reaper Leviathans
Then im gonna need me some gosh darn, gosh darn
*Moment of silence*
Decoys...
But after that, you may be wondering...
Am I just charging into these leviathans willy nilly, just to get my kicks and giggles out of it?
No
I say to you
Oh, intrepent viewer of thine
Though I'm going in there because there is still the shield module
And the Sonar fragment
And I dont know if I'm gonna be able to get both in this one episode, but i'm gonna try my damndest to do that
And i'm not gonna...beach my goddamned cyclops
here i'm gonna go in there im gonna get the batteries and then im gonna pop back out
and then i'm gonna make myself some goddamned decoys
But in the mountain area and in the koosh zone
I've been told there are wrecks
Which contain that which I need, and what I need, in fact
is- (Welcome Aboard Captain)-OHHHH-I NEED TO PUT THAT BACK IN MEH CYCLOPS
BECAUSE-IM DUMB, but what is in those wrecks is something
SO INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT that I won't be able to get
back down into the briny depths without them
Yes, the shield and the other thing that I need
The sonar, the mapping feature which can help me
navigate and also know where the hecky I'm going in life
So with those two tools,
and Jeffrey, Billy, Samwise, and Marshall,
Nah, I don't need them at all
But with those two tools, I should be able to get back down there
and I should be able to make that which I  need
to be able to carry on with my life
Now, energy pulse origin, I already know about that
that was the mountain area which I'm already headed back towards
Now some of you said that the mountain area
er, the gun, did have a working portal in it
and I think I vaguely remember that
I think I actually remember powering it up
and activating, but it may not be activated just yet
So, while I go backwards and I go over towards the reaper leviathans
I'm going to read these comments here
uh, I don't have time to make lockers just yet
but everybody, thank you so much
Micha Warmel who said
"I'm not exactly sure but maybe making the submarine
a neon yellow color is not helping you go unnoticed, Mark."
Well, I just wanna die in a yellow submarine
Is that so much for me to ask?
And then SanDeity said, "This episode should have been called
'Mark's Massacre' because of how many fish
he killed out of their homes and the poor civilian boomerang
he murdered and didn't think twice about!"
Well here's something I thought twice about, maybe he deserved it!
You don't know what that boomerang did, you don't know that that boomerang
was not the conspirator leader of all the leviathans
in this entire ocean.
As unlikely and as crazy as that may sound,
it could be true.
I'm going to go silent running
Because I know for a fact that I might actually be in Reaper Leviathan territory...
OH it's so scary!
OH it's so SCARY!
AAAHH it's so scary!
Okay
Then there's PaulPurr_tf2TheSniperWithSkillz
who said: "Mark don't worry, the devs thankfully made it so that if the Cyclops does meet the
watery grave, the upgrades and built items can be reclaimed/salvaged
from the remains of the Cyclops if you can reach it."
*Karen* "Caution: blood nutrient levels decreasing. Calorie intake recommended."
Yeah I know, I get it Karen. I'm starving, it's real good to know about!
"Also, all the titanium for pressure compensators aren't gone forever"
So if I do eventually crash this some bitch,
And it does die
to a Reaper Leviathan attack
I VOW
I will not restart my save
I will take that punishment for what it is
~and that is why I'm going to be
UNBELIEVABLY CAREFUL in these briny depths
Because I'm putting a challenge to myself
to NOT CHEAT!
And I think resetting my save
(cuts himself off) and I only get a few of those in the entire series that I gotta do so I gotta
be very careful about that
Also! MaxWait said:
"Mark, try to put up your 'Keep Calm Kitty' poster
in the Cyclops now that it's updated."
And YES *Spoilers: Still.... Can't...*
I've been keeping the 'Keep Calm
*stutters*
Kitty' poster right here on me the entire time.
Because... It Keeps Me Happy At Night *Lemme Hug You Mark (T-T\)*
It Keeps Me Warm....
Makes Me Feel Comfortable..
In This DARK DREARY ENVIRONMENT, WHERE EVERYTHING IS DEATH *Which Is Sad*
I Feel Just A Little Bit A Comfort
Which Is Nice :D
I Need To Get A Few More Of These-
I Gotta Empty Up My Inventory Very Soon, I've Got All These Batteries
But Imma Make A Bunch Of Decoys-
*Bigboxbarry.exe Error:404*
AWW, COME ON....
I THOUGHT IT WAS NINE. I ONLY DID EIGHT THERE
AH GODDAMMIT. DAMN YOU! DAMN YOU TO HELL!!
-Alright. Needs Someone With The Empty One.. *Who's That Mark?*
NOT YOU!
I've Got So Much Titanium!
Jeez! I'd Didn't Think Too Many Resources Here
Alright, so I need some of these baaaatteries
And I need some titaaaanium
Thank you for that
And then what else did I need?
I needed the...
*Thinking*
What did I need?
*More thinking*
Copper wire, do I have any copper left?
Man, that was actually the one thing I was running out of
I don't even know if I have any co– *GASP*
I have copper, but only enough to make one copper wire
I want at least two of these decoys here
YEESSS!
I've got some more, okay so I make the copper wire
Like that shaboosky
And then I make another one of those
Like that shaaabloosky!
And then I'm gonna make myself a goddamn decoy tube
Which is hopefully gonna be very, very useful, and I'm gonna use it in emergencies
Which is gonna happen literally ALL THE TIME that I'm in the ocean
I may PANIC and FIRE IT OFF and I may not look/think twice about it
But I'm gonna do that
I'm gonna build a locker right next to it so
I can have all the storage for the
torpedoes that I make there
but I'mma load this bad boy up
I'mma load this bad boy up
And, I'mma Eat This Bad Boys Here.
cause I just purged everything so I might as well have some in the gullet
God dammit freaking inventory full
Ok whatever that's going to be good enough
And, I'mma drop off the rest of the bullshit that's in my inventory
Because, I am just loaded to the ears.
With ALL of this garbo.
ALL of this garbo.
God- so much garbo.
HABADABADU
boop boop
Ok, that's gonna have to do it.
Ah, creature decoy, i'm going to put you away for now because I don't really need you in the moment.
I'm gonna take the batteries too.
And then I'm gonna try- to put the
But I don't think it's gonna work, is it?
Alright, here we go!
Come on, please, please-
Why? WHY?
Why would you deprive me of this?
Game developers, why?!
Also, I know that the game developers have apparently made a Markiplier doll somewhere in the game-
I don't know how to get to it, but I am aware that that exists.
So, without further ado-
I'm gonna save anyway just because, you know, why not?
Why wouldn't I do that, why wouldn't I save?
But I'm gonna save, and then I'm diving down.
Op, I'm facing the wrong direction here
But I'm gonna dive down...
I'm about to go-
Oh, of course! It's gonna be night, right now. But we're gonna go.
Down into the briny depths...
And we're gonna see...
We're gonna see exactly what we need to know about.. down here.
Ohh boy, howdy, ohhh boy.
OHHH BOY HOWDY OHH BOY
Ah, god, nah- ok
So all I need to do is I need to go down, in there, into the koosh zone.
And I need to find myself in the piTCH DARKNESS THAT IT IS.
I need to find wherever the hell the goddamn...
wreck is down here and that's not the wreck that
I went to looking for the-- the plans for
that thing that I can't remember what it
is right now because, ah, my brain is not
working... but I'm looking for the other
wreck that is a part of the koosh zone specifically.
Not the deeper areas-- I'm
looking specifically for the wreck in
the koosh zone and given that I can't see
dack diddly...
I am goddamn gonna die. I'm not gonna
give up because I'm above the mushroom
area which is far north and I think just
to the west (nope) -- or just to the east of this...
I just pissed myself again but I think I
see it in front of me. The koosh zone is
over there, I believe, or is that the Aurora?
Oh, I can hardly tell. I think I need to go lower.
I'm not 100% sure. Let me cycle... okay. So I'm not very
deep so that's probably my problem
right now but I'm pretty sure that
somewhere below me
adjacent to the mushroom forest is the
koosh zone... ugh. Ordinarily, this would be FINE.
Ordinarily I'd be TOTALLY FINE with this!
Everything would be hunky-dory! AGH but
DEATH lurks around every corner in the
ocean, and I am going to BRACE it--
Embrace it. I'm going to brace it and
then embrace it then punch it in its
goddamn face. I'm gonna die and
everything is gonna be horrible... but
until that moment comes, I'm gonna go
into the koosh zone. If I keep shouting my
plans, is it any more reassuring, or am I
just making you guys worried out there? (Yes.)
*whispers* Koosh. I see it. Okay. I spied some koosh... I've got
some sweet, dank koosh over there... okay. So
I don't-I don't have the coordinates
specifically-- oohhhh. Hi, you guys! Don't come
near me! I'm siiilent running... I'm silent
running. You would never bother someone
that's silent running with glasses, would you?
Okay, then. Oh. Was that the sound of those (FROM HERE ON OUT, THIS IS AUTOMATED.)
sharks was that the sound of something
bigger okay somewhere here in the
goddamn cusan hi oh I hate you I hate
you I hate all of you oh I hate you all
so much
okay somewhere down here goddamn coup
zone there is a wreck I don't think I'm
gonna find the wreck by going oh so
tantalizingly slow
what is that what is that down there
that's a life pod I didn't know that
there was a life pod in the couch zone I
thought there was a rack is no this
isn't what I'm looking for when I what I
saw this bill specifically I don't have
the exact coordinates for it but they
were specifically there was specifically
a rack here a giant wreck not just a
life pod but frankly I didn't even know
if there was a life pod here in the
first place I honestly had no idea so I
don't know what this is going to contain
if anything useful it might be something
that I already have the fact that
there's a life up here right but I'm oh
my god okay thank you for that okay
hello I am I must have been something I
already had the plans to okay but I
don't remember ever getting a life pod
down here I don't ever remember that
like pots well that doesn't sound
familiar but I decided been here I'm
going to get back with a don't feel safe
out here on my own especially with the
goddamn lava burst, okay so we got a
new dataset here and I don't
know if it's going to be something new
for me but I'm going to look at it log
data downloads, life pods, life pod 12
this is medical officer Danby in life
pod twelve I'm braking atmosphere at
high velocity planet fall in 20 seconds
explosion taking fire going into a spin
attempting
landed in an area of significant alien
activity encountered predators in the
Leviathan class highly aggressive
spectroscope skinner assigned them
Reaper oh so that's how they got their
names I don't remember if I've ever read
that you don't find me on board the ship
presume I miscalculated and save yourself
oh this is new! one specimen attempted
to swallow the lifepod doing extensive
damage in the process only viable
option is to make for the safety of the
Aurora crash site, I've retrieved the
data box with the alien creature decoy
blueprint and enough resources to
fabricate a couple decoys the swims
longer than the decoy lifetime but it
should be just enough to keep them busy
if you don't find me on board the ship
presume I miscalculated and save
yourself oh oh I can't even imagine doing
that swim I can't even imagine doing that swim
that that would be the most horrifying
swim
anyone's ever done in their life what is
that hey back off okay you back off oh
mama
okay so what I get to do is I got to
find I got to find uh I got to find this
big wreck because I know there's a
bigger wreck here and that explains why
that life pod was upside down and in a
bad way whoo wait I think I see
something yeah that's definitely a wreck
okay in that wreck supposedly I say
supposedly with a lot of grain of salt
happening but supposedly in that wreck
is the plans for the either sonar or not
sonar
so either way I need to go in there I
need to go in there and I need to
digging biggest cave down there I'm
gonna go ahead and assume that's not a
cave that I can go into but there are
some low framerates around yeah I need I
need I need I need I need I need ice
like I'm playing on a potato here I'm
gonna go in there anyway cuz I'm brave
or whatever here we go diddly doo I'm
off squadala
I'm off oh my god oh my god this oh
that's janky oh here starvation imminent
you shut up oh man I'm just got so that
was good Ian what did they give me
there's got to be something else in here
then skadoosh skinny husky skidoo
skadoosh skadoosh off skadoosh who's in
here Oh such sweet frames brah oh yes
disinfected water brah
oh I need the laser cutter for this I
need oh oh my god whys the frame rate so
long here I think this still has the
crap battery in it so eventually I'll
need to upgrade this to the better
battery that definitely is not working
but hopefully I can I have the swim
charge fins so if I swim around enough
while holding this thing and should get
me a double dagger of a little more
power is there anything in here that I
can use just a battery I guess it's
technically useful but not literally
useful I'm about to run out of oxygen
aren't I and I don't see ah haha so
janky okay I'm out of here
mater your baby doesn't seem to be
charging it at all I don't care I gotta
go
alright gotta go alright Oh charged it
one per shaunt okay but it didn't give
me it didn't give me the sonar upgrade
and that's not a factor of the save this
is on the retail version so that should
be there but there also is another
location
for said device so if it's not in
another spot in there somewhere then
that means that it's got to be somewhere
else and that means I got to go to the
mountainous area which by itself is
currently interest why I don't know what
I had but it was something so I think
I'm going in the right direction for the
seems to be a lot of enemies out there I
don't like that very much but there seem
to be a lot of them okay but it's fine
it I think I'm heading towards where the
mountains are I can probably stand to
make a little bit of noise in fact I'll
cut it I'll cut it when I don't need it
I know I'm cavitating but I'll cut it as
soon as I don't need it anymore
okay somewhere here there be love I
advanced and again I'm gonna be real
stupid and I'm gonna see if they bother
me because at some point I'm gonna have
to test this out if I'd rather do it in
a controlled environment than have it
happen to me you know what I mean you
guys know what I'm talking about guys
know what I mean I'd rather see for
myself and then run with a few decoy
then have them just spring upon me this
is weird because I swear I swear they're
supposed to be leviathans around here
okay so far so good
so far so good okay um either I'm
extremely lucky or beige ain't something
because I'm wrong the bone jerk
hey buddy no need to worry about me it's
just us it's a big yellow submarine
friend Oh cover give me a big hog give
me a big ol hug
so either either I'm lucky or they
change something which is concerning to
say the least because it makes me feel
like they just took the Reaper
leviathans and put them all very densely
in one location which I love it I don't
think that's any better than what I had
going on there maybe that's any better
at all but I am in the mountainous area
which means in here somewhere there are
more wrecks and I know there is the one
wreck that's draped across the bodies of
like the underwater islands or the
underwater mountains or whatever you
want to call them and I think that's got
one of the things and then in the
mountainous area themselves as I piss
myself there are more wrecks with more
of these specialized equipment and I'm
guessing it must be some sort of
randomize because that's what it was
before when I was trying to find
everything so with that being said I'm
going to find one more wreck and then
that's going to be the end of this
episode because I want to try to find
something something oh I can't see shit
oh here we go keep getting closer we're
getting who is that a date abox that
looks like a dative box I don't know if
that's gonna be the data box that I'm
looking for who keeps me silently run
here no no no you didn't see anything I
got to get me some food and then I get
to give me some goddamn repairs because
I'm not doing 100 then okay on this woo
boy
Pirlo frames again hopping out there
whether or not it is a good idea I'm
still gonna do it okay anybody hoppity
hippity hoppity oh-oh I didn't get any
III hey hey hey I didn't get it oh my
god there's a rack here how long was
there reckon you oh you don't I think I
just saw the inside of my soul there for
a second there but I think I'm okay
there are a lot of juice bags here they
want a piece of me but I won't let them
have it
oh that's okay you'll survive big guy
cuz I didn't get anything from there and
I'm pretty sure I'm only not getting
things
ah shit oh shit oh shit open this open
this up in this hey don't hit me while
I'm opening something that just be rude
here we go go go go go go all right I
don't think they can follow me in here
so I should be okay looking for some
sort of it I there we go
all right then can we do something good
nah nothing again all right
I'm gonna keep looking around just in
case you never know
come on you come on caught on got it
there we go keep swimming back and forth
is this going to charge you this is
charging it they're doing you they're
doing what you need how does that feel I
feel good feel good feel charged find it
whoa hi I got a dated terminal let's go
there's another one in here
Cyclops fire suppression system does
awesome that sounds awesome
I don't know what that do but that
sounds whoo awesome okay I want to get a
little bit of start oh I can make it out
of there how do you make it out in time
I don't know if I'm gonna have enough
power for this but I'm gonna try to make
it maybe I'll make it I don't know if
ah its gonna be close I'm gonna make it oh I should probably
go I'm gonna go Oh low framerates can't
see shit get through the goddamn door
please oh god where do I go I've totally
gone where I'm going oh boy I'm gonna be
doing this in the dark where is my
goddamn boat oh it's over here
oh I'm an idiot yo yo yo yo ed shubbu
ski no okay
well that could have gone better or
could have gone worse so I'd say that
did marginally good for exactly the way
it was so with that being said I'm all
at time for this episode so I am going
to leave it here thankfully I didn't
encounter a Leviathan but that just
means that I'm going to encounter a
Leviathan in the next episode no matter
what I do because I'm going to force
myself to encounter a Leviathan in next
episode so thank you everybody so much
for watching let me know how I'm doing
down to comes below I did get the fire
suppression system which means that over
here I hope that means that over here it
should listen to recipe and it's oh my
god when did I get that did I actually
get that well I don't have enough
polyaniline for that oh it's a lot of
shit and it needs but hey it's pretty
good so I've got those two recipes
apparently now and that means I'll be
able to do more damage with it so thank
you everybody so much for watching it
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
(Markiplier background plays)